as far as
uh being united even though our
country's name is united
and you know we are the united states of
america and
china we don't have a clue what's going
on over there because you can never
tell the debates they're having
internally amongst their politicians
because that's never public that's
private to them it's their business they
don't think
it's our business to know what's going
on over there so we're like the husband
and wife we're our uh
we're u.s is more like keeping up the
kardashians and china is more like a
very
private show that only they know about
everything we do is publicized right we
know everything
the world knows our problems our drama
everything yeah
we have a short attention span and we
have a a tendency here in the states to
uh you know think
i don't want to make this sound too
simplistic but
we do uh tend to in this country
um think the best right of other
nations for the most part right we or
maybe it's not even that maybe it's just
we imagine
that we're all in the same boat together
somehow and we mirror
our values or the way that we see
ourselves or would like to see ourselves
onto other nations right so that hampers
our negotiations sometimes
when you're talking about a country like
china or russia um
you know the iranian regime the north
koreans because
we you know we don't sometimes seem to
understand how ruthless
they are and how uh
singularly focused they are on their own
best interests
well we're not we're the complete
opposite so
who who can be bought more is is u.s
more for sale or is china more for sale
well i think we're more easily
distracted uh in terms of
yeah i i think yeah i mean it's a very
interesting question
it's phrased very interestingly um
you know i think the problem with with
uh with the way that we approach
china is that look the past four years
um
and i you know didn't have a dog in the
hunt
in the past you know presidential thing
i you know
i like i like republican policies i
don't necessarily need to like the
person who's leading them
right um but
i think we had a relatively honest
open discussion about china for the
first time in quite some time right
some of the actions that were done some
of the things that were said
um i think it actually put the chinese
regime on their back foot they weren't
expecting
sort of that behavior because for
decades we've always approached china in
the same way
and always expect the same sort of
result that somehow they're going to
gravitate towards a more democratic
society that's horseshit
you know as long as she's in charge she
has set himself up much like
much like putin look putin's going to be
president until he dies
right and she has pretty much done the
same thing and he has completely
locked down the security services uh he
squashed any hope of any pro-democracy
movement in hong kong
uh the the genocide with the uyghurs and
yet we continue sometimes to act as if
you know hey
you know these are people that we can
understand and work with and we've got
aligned interests and
you know maybe once in a generation our
interests actually align
yeah i mean it's it's is uh you you see
so much so much of the world relying
on this one country china whether it's
manufacturing whether it's
chips we learned during kovit we kind of
need these guys for pharmaceuticals you
saw what happened with india
400 000 people a day getting covered and
the officials of china send a tweet
essentially on their web on a on their
own twitter
website called weibo making fun of uh
india what they're going through versus
how look at us we took a you know
a a rocket launcher and these guys are
blowing up over there and then they took
it down because they got heat from their
own people that
called out the officials in china and uh
now india desperately needs 1.2 billion
vaccines and who's the only place in the
world that can get
their 1.2 billion vaccines and all the
intel all the negotiations the trade
secrets that they picked up
is it too late meaning yesterday i think
60 minutes was done what a few days
ago with anthony belkin uh uh uh i'm
pronouncing his wrong
name wrong blinking and
the the lady asked the question saying
by 2028 china's
poised to be a bigger gdp than u.s right
is it is it already are we at the point
of no return where china is going to be
the largest empire in the world and it's
going to be very hard to compete against
those guys
well that's the narrative that they push
and and and part of what
china's engaged in is sort of
information warfare
right so so they've been beating that
drum that look it's inevitable
china's heading towards the top of the
food chain um
you know the us is a nation in decline
those things are
talking points at the uh that the
chinese
propaganda machine has been pushing out
for some time and they're very good at
it they're very effective at it we talk
about russian disinformation all the
time but that
you know the chinese have far more
resource um
than uh than the russians do and they've
been very aggressive and
active in trying to make sure that not
just that message gets out here in the
u.s but that it gets out to all those
nations whether it's in latin america or
africa or anywhere else
where the chinese regime has been very
busy uh trying to
uh you know basically put a variety of
nations into debt
through their belt and road program uh
lock up as much
of the you know rare earth mineral
commodities as possible and
and other and look they've got their
first overseas port now you know sitting
in in uh djibouti
in africa and um
that's not by accident that's by design
they are pushing out their military
aggressiveness in a
concerning way a very concerning way
there seem to be kind of accelerating
their timetable
uh internally when it comes to their
thought process towards taiwan
um so is it is it inevitable
uh no not by any means they've got a lot
of problems
they've got internally there's a lot
more protest that goes on internally in
china than more aware of
um you know there is corruption that
exists within that that
uh that uh government that
you know can at any time cause one of
their people to topple right
so you know it's a very it's in a way
it's it's it's a relatively frail
system and that's why she has been so
busy trying to
lock it down you know for his own
purposes and and
uh his longevity you believe that you
you believe it's a frail
empire where well no what i mean is i
mean
parts of the parts of the way the
organization and look i mean frankly i
you know i maybe i'm just stupid
and old school and and you know but
um you know socialism communism
you know they you china's been around a
long time communism
has not right communist china has not
been around a long time
so when we think of china you don't you
you don't think
well this system has been around forever
no it hasn't so what i'm saying is
there's the frailty built into communism
and
socialism that eventually i believe uh
outs itself right comes out and
and then you know we see the decline in
whatever
nation it happens to be so uh
that's what i'm talking about i mean
they you know it may not happen
you know next year obviously or the next
decade or in our lifetime but
yeah i don't hold any water and thinking
somehow that china is inevitably the
next powerhouse
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
[Music]